today's episode is brought to you by
liquid death
today's guest is a valiant man valiant
young man
he's from australia if you believe in
that
and he is a uh
he's a world-class gold medalist
in scooter games and in bmx
uh by cycling
this man has done things and you and i
could never fathom doing
even our dreams we can't do the things
that this man does in actuality
he's a member of the nitro circus he's
won countless gold medals he's uh from
australia
and we are so happy to have him here
today mr ryan
williams
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right mate
yeah
how you feeling man i feel good yeah did
you have a good time i'm sitting here
with ryan williams um
who was a real
uh
cyclist i guess is a you know a
real astronaut
cyclist almost
ex-gamer what's kind of the appropriate
term for somebody like you uh i guess
you would say a professional bmx writer
and a professional scooter writer okay
action sports athlete okay try to do it
all you do yeah okay so
and um
action sports
like
so when you when people say action
sports that encompasses what
um anything that's kind of like i guess
i guess slightly dangerous
and
considered a sport
okay i would say so yeah
and um
and i saw you last night we went to the
comedy show yeah yeah it was sick
yeah it was it was so good and i was
like uh i don't know i've only been to
um the comedy store like before that
yeah and then um so this is like the
second time going somewhere in hollywood
yeah oh nice yeah
um
so yeah you guys uh yeah that was such a
surprise dude so do you have do you go
to a place uh so you live in australia
right yeah yeah and do you is there a
comedy place you go to there yeah no
i've actually never seen a comedy show
in australia wow yeah
but um so yeah i'm living here in
huntington beach but
um usually sunshine coast in a show and
you've been to australia right yeah i've
been to australia man i really like
australia
you know i like a lot of i like how it
all started with the inmates and
everything putting all like the seedy
people over there yeah yeah i love seedy
people
and so i think i love that about it you
know just seeing the children and
grandchildren of seedy people
and just seeing like the ant you know
all the unique animals
it feels almost like a pla it feels
almost like a um
like a secret location kind of you know
yeah uh or it seems like a um
like a practice facility for humanity
that's what and
and mother nature it feels like a
training ground for like humans and
mother nature that's what i feel like
just to see how it like mixes i feel
like it helps uh it must be like in the
blood because i feel like a lot of us
have like a few screws loose and that's
why why you see us in action sports like
just sending it yeah oh there's a
different level yeah australians have a
different thing inside of them and i
don't know if it's a sign do they know
if it's a scientific thing you think
like if it's like a uh maybe
generational i don't know
i wonder if there's like that rebellious
thing because
because australia started because i
think they were inmates from england
they put them there right yeah yeah so
there was like convicts and they um
shipped them over because it was like
they're like oh we want to free up some
space here
so send them off to the mainland a
little we need a little more bandwidth
over here at the prison
so we're going to send we're going to
send a couple uh a couple of bad boys
over there
yeah dude i love australia man i had a
great time um
so how do so so your world is mostly
like take me through how you kind of got
started man because i know you and i
just met on ig i was in like i love all
your like tricks and it seems so extreme
and like i get nervous being at like
high speeds and stuff so when i see
somebody like you i'm like damn this guy
you know he's really able to level up
like in this um
you know this guy seems like a real like
a you know uh
just like a real energy drink of a kind
of guy you know i felt like yeah um i
don't know i guess it started like
where the action sport started was i
watched the x games and like there was a
movie called the ultimate x and it had
like guys like travis pastrana tony hawk
and like i seen that and i think all i
had at the time were like rollerblades
because my mum took me to the roller
drum you know so
i was like i want to go to skatepark now
what do i have rollerblades so i just
like went to this game i got my roll
blades and fell on my butt like 500
times and then pretty much from then on
i was just like the skatepark rat right
you know skatepark kid and so at
skateparks over there are people doing
drugs and stuff or is it mostly just
skating um you could probably find drugs
at the skate park but
i like
there's certain skateparks like the
skatepark i mainly go to it's got a
fence around it so you don't just go
chill there and do drugs you kind of
like pay to go in and you're not going
to pay twice to do drugs yeah yeah it's
true yeah
yeah
yeah if you do your drugs and then you
go in there yeah you want to save that
money i think and just do your drugs
outside probably yeah um
so when you started like did you find
that you were good at in in the
beginning because sometimes i wonder how
much of a um
to be like an extreme
sports person yeah how much like
how much like um
is it in you and then how much is it
that you can learn like oh yeah
i've always felt like something like
that is not in me dude like
yeah you know i'll even like even you
know sometimes people like when the car
stops real fast people put their hand
over the person yeah yeah i will make
people put their hand over me even if
we're just kind of cruising along
yeah i guess um i would say i guess it
is built in a little bit like you kind
of have to be a little bit wild because
you've got to get over the hill you know
you're going to crash you are going to
crash there's like no way not to really
if you want to push that upper level but
i guess it is something you could
definitely learn like obviously i
started i started just for fun and i was
just like all my homies were like down
the skate park and then that's why i
jumped on a scooter because i was like
the only rollerblade kid just all like
the lonely rollerblader basically down
the skate park and all my mates rode
scooters and i was like man i want to
ride with i want to learn with everybody
else so i ended up like i had to borrow
like their scooter and their shoes
because obviously i rolled the blade i
didn't have shoes you can't roll the
blade on the scooter yet no well you're
kidding if you try enough but uh yeah
pretty much just
oh it was all fun at the start and then
you like build up and just i don't know
you slowly progress but i guess at the
start you obviously
have to be able to get hurt and not like
cry about it kind of thing you have to
like get pick yourself up and keep going
and if you see somebody with like were
you helmeted in the beginning are people
in helmets or not yeah yeah helmeted and
is it well received by others if you
wear a helmet or is it kind of it's a
it's um it depends what you're doing
like you're not going to go out there
and do a triple backflip with no helmet
on because
you if you crash then you're not going
to be doing any more flips after that
you know you know like you can get
seriously hurt but definitely like the
skateboarding realm is like yeah if you
don't you're not wearing if you're
wearing a helmet like olly in a stair
set they're like what are you doing yeah
but
it's kind of well received in scooter
and bmx to wear the helmet because a lot
of people have gotten hurt even with the
helmet on and like can't ride anymore so
it's like if everyone wasn't wearing a
helmet then there'd be way less bmx
riders because i think that oh it's that
it gets that dangerous huh it definitely
does get dangerous and it's just like
why not have
a helmet on and just protect your noggin
yeah i just always i would never want my
kids i don't think to see me in a helmet
you know if i'm a dad you know yeah like
that's such a yeah i don't know yeah i
guess you might not suit a helmet i
don't think i've ever seen a picture of
you in a helmet so yeah
and there's only a reason for that yeah
probably a reason for it yeah but i
think yeah if a kid sees their dad in a
helmet i think it just does something to
a kid that it's just hard to like you
guys helmets is different because
they're more like cool looking helmets i
feel like but if you're in like one of
like if you're like on a bicycle like in
the neighborhood and you were and your
dad drives up the driveway in the bike
and he has on a helmet i feel like it
just
i don't know i would feel so sad for my
dad and then i feel so sad for me i
think
yeah i guess like if you're wearing a
cyclist helmet the worst ones i think i
don't know if you have like birds that
sweep you here like we have magpies in
australia and they like swoop you so you
see cyclists they'll they'll have like a
cycling helmet and then they'll have zip
ties
like pointing up in the air to keep them
keep the birds from sweeping their heads
that's crazy dude yeah i used to paint
this this uh
i used to paint fences on this man's
property and i used to do it with this
big uh
kind of urban gentleman and he died
actually but
he was alive at this point and we used
to he also used to cut grass his dude
johnny was his name big johnny and he
wore these he had like it was big he had
a real dark skin and he had a big chest
here and he would have these jewel like
a lot of gold and stuff and
silver choice chains and stuff in it and
he was a homosexual guy actually i
didn't know that at the time but people
said he was later
but anyway he um
the birds would come he and i would
paint these fences and the birds would
swoop down because he had a big afro so
the birds would swoop down to get into
his hair yeah so at one point my only
responsibility was to have this like
badminton racket and just [ __ ] swat
away all like these uh i want to say it
was nightingales but it might have been
something else they're trying to like
nest yeah they coming in and trying to
nest at him he's like you got my back
i'm like i got you bud so i'm just
sitting there all day just [ __ ] just
uh just love love with mother nature um
but
but anyway yeah so because yeah i think
sometimes if i had that helmet it would
make me
if i saw my dad on a regular bicycle but
in your sport you guys need the helmet
yeah yeah i'd suggest wearing a helmet
just because you could like not even be
trying anything crazy and just like fall
over and just hit your head and there's
like a there's a lot of guys that like
have had brain injuries and then they
can't ride and it's like if they
and there's big people that get hurt not
wearing a helmet and can't ride so it's
like may as well just wear one but i get
where you're coming from but i'll stick
to wearing helmet i think yeah
yeah
um so what about this so you get going
you now was it frowned upon that you're
in there with the uh rollerblades was
that kind of like a yeah well yeah it
was because i i rolled away for like
four years but it was kind of like
that's all i had you know right i was
just my i was uh i grew up with a single
mom and she was like
that's all we could afford right we just
had the rollerblades and then it's like
i was like sweet and then once i started
i was like man this is fun like this is
so fun i'm just gonna rollerblade
because it's so fun it's the only thing
i tried yeah so i did that for like four
years
i can't imagine rollerblading for four
years man
and so then you you get up to the
scooter so is that where you start to
like make your like where do you start
to kind of make your climb into like
this [ __ ] like astrophysicist on a
scooter like you're like this like
you're like a bullet kind of like where
do you start to make your climb then um
i would say like
i jump on a scooter i think i rode for
like maybe
three or four years and then kind of got
sponsored and then once i got sponsored
that we did like a trip to um the usa
and that was like when i was like what
like i'm riding a scooter and like
they're flying me over to the usa to
just ride skateparks this is like kind
of like mind-blowing this is crazy so
where were you riding when you're riding
before you're still at these skate parks
locally yeah all just the skate parks
and then for about
so yeah for about five five or six years
it was just the skate park stuff and
then that's
like after that nitrous soaker see me on
youtube right and they were like oh
let's give this guy go on this 40-foot
jump and then see what he can do and i
was like let's go i was 17 years old
just like
ready to send it you didn't want it so
you didn't have any so like yeah was
there a lot of fear or anything like
what goes
what starts to go away does the fear
start to go away or take me through some
of that process because you're
let's see if we can pull up one of these
um
just pull up one of uh i just want you
to kind of take me through what's what
some of this is when you like because
now you do some pretty you're on like
some pretty intense ramps huh yeah
um
probably go like just a single trick
don't do that
just typing like triple front flip
that's a good one that's probably my
hardest one on scooter okay let's look
for that one you just triple front flip
in the top
ah now down one yep there we go
i'm probably just skipping a little bit
but
this one was crazy because it was like
they built this jump just for me to do
this trick wow
and like the thing is i'm always scared
like i'm always scared the fear is
always there it's just the confidence is
built built up you know i've gained
confidence in my abilities in myself hey
hold on we can hear that in here it's
too loud in here
sorry
yeah i don't even think we need the
audio of it if we can
we can probably just look at the video
okay so right here so they're building
this they built this ramp so this was at
travis australia's house so is this when
you once you get on this is this once
you get over here to the u.s yeah yeah
on this tour nah not that first tour
this is like after i've been on nitro
circus and then i'm like this is when
i'm kind of
really starting my career look wow yeah
but this is
you look like a full-on
dame from [ __ ] adelaide bro you look
like a yeah i don't know i don't know
what look i was going for there but yeah
um they built this ramp just for this
trick and i was so scared because no one
had ever landed a triple front flip on
bmx and it's still like one of the
hardest tricks i've ever done even
though this is like
i don't know seven years ago
dude now did you did these guys think
you could do it are guys like psyched
for each other is it like a lot of
camaraderie yeah that's the thing about
action sports is that like we know that
if the other guy doesn't land it like he
can get really hurt so it's all just
like we're all homies everyone's
cheering everyone on no one wants anyone
to fail we want everyone to win right
and this is my homie i was actually
racing him to do the first one and he
he got he got to do the first attempt
and yeah you'll see it's just
explosion jesus
yeah
and is that a children's bike
i mean kind of it's a full gra it's a
full man bike oh okay yeah
a kid could ride it though
yeah it was not it was it was wild wow
so when you're going up this like what
speed are you going whenever you hit
this whenever you go up this ramp i
think we had a speed speedometer and it
was like 35 miles per hour 35 40.
yeah
and so all right so you get on this bike
i just like what i do is kind of like
you can close your you know you can
close your eyes and you can write your
name you know right you know so it's
like that i've i've wrote a bmx so long
that
i can like picture it in my head before
i even do it so it's like i just close
my eyes and i like have like a simulator
in my brain that i've
created over like 15 years of riding
action sports and i can just play that
trick out boom boom in my head 30 times
before i drop in and then i drop in and
it's like okay this is what i have to do
i'm doing it and i'm as i'm doing it i'm
like calculating okay is this what was
meant to be happening is this what i
imagined was going to be happening right
and if it is i'm like sweet stay on and
if i'm looking and i'm seeing something
else i'm like all right how am i not how
do i not land on my head right now right
so at a certain point it's just you
realize it's kind of survival like if
it's if something feels a little bit off
or something you realize at that point i
just needed a land i need to land safely
and redo it yeah yeah exactly so like
i'm a professional crasher i would say
as well to be a professional action
sports athlete you have to be a
professional crasher because
if you if you can't crash then you can't
get back up and try again
manscaped has been busy and just
launched the redefined body wash and
two-in-one shampoo plus conditioner
they have everything you need to take
care of your body
and keep your hair
tidy damn it do well look decent it's
your crotch christ
you know that new lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
from manscaped
god
it really does if you want that male
landing strip if you want to put them uh
buck antlers
above your wiener or that antenna
that old tv antenna like your
grandfather used to have and watch the
ball games
you can do it well for your own dick and
crotch and female
crotch area you can do it manskate
manscape.com is where you want to go to
get it
slash theo
the performance package includes that
weed whacker
do your uh
edge your garden
edge you cut dude if your friend's in a
coma trim his crotch up while he's out
next thing you know he wakes up in
february march or something
early summer he wakes up and damn
his damn crotch looks better
get that christmas package to take care
of your package
you can do it get 20 off in free
shipping by going to manscape.com
t-h-e-o
that's 20 off and free shipping i'm in a
basement right now in vermont
so i'm doing
i'm do i've probably been doing better
godspeed
you know cash back cards are so 20 20.
you buy this you buy a thing of skittles
you get half a cent back
you buy 50 worth of damn corn and you
get a uh
they send you a mitten or something one
mitten
you got to keep high-fiving people with
your cold hand
to keep it warm
the [ __ ] has to stop
well whether you're a crypto pro or a
total beginner you can finally earn
bitcoin
the easy way with the world's first
bitcoin rewards credit card from block
fi
yep you can earn unlimited bitcoin in
every qualifying purchase you make
if you're interested in buying bitcoin
but don't know where to start block fi
has the world's first bitcoin rewards
card
card
so you can earn bitcoin the easiest way
possible with every qualifying purchase
yep
the block five rewards visa signature
card
that's right you can earn 1.5 percent
back in bitcoin on all qualifying
purchases now is the time to start or
ramp up your bitcoin portfolio
our listeners can get a bonus of 25
dollars in crypto
after you make your first purchase
with the credit card when you sign up at
block five.com
theo that's 25 bonus encrypted deposited
right into your account
after you make your first purchase go to
blockkfi.com
t-h-e-o
yep
not all will be eligible geographic
regulatory and underwriting restrictions
apply fees and terms are subject to
change
additional terms of service at
blockfy.com blackfy is a financial
technology company banking services
provided by evolve bank and trust member
fdic
start earning bitcoin back on all your
qualifying purchase today blockfy.com
theo okay so on that on that trick right
there are you doing what is that trick
called that was a triple front flip on
bmx okay
and it never been done before no inhuman
by human by anybody
but i don't think by anyone maybe yeah i
haven't seen any animals do anything so
if you
when you're going up you're going up
that ramp how do you then get your bike
to flip
frontward because it would seem like you
want to go back have you ever done a
flip
um i've done a flip on a trampoline yeah
and it's kind of similar to that but
it's like obviously wheels different
inertia but it's like so what i do
the way i do it is i would ride up right
and then i i initiate the front flip by
throwing my upper body over the front of
the bike right and then it's going to
tip the bike up when do you do that like
do you know when to do it yeah i have to
do it a little bit early on that triple
front flip because obviously it's three
flips not one like one flip you can be
like like just chill and it comes around
two flips then you have to get more
three flips is like okay i just have to
put everything into it and i actually
like nose manual which is like where you
go on the front wheel so i'll be going
on one wheel up the ramp before i'm even
off the top and then that's what just
flicks me and then wow so when you leave
the ramp you're only on that front wheel
yeah on that trick wow because i have to
just give it everything can you feel
that front wheel catch the edge of that
ramp at all or not yeah it hits that
trick the funny thing is i have bru i
had bruises on my legs because
the bike would like press against my
legs so hard because i would throw so
hard that the handlebars would hit me in
the legs and that's how i knew i was
spinning fast because i was like oh yeah
i felt that and you then you feel the
flick and you just kind of like hold on
for the ride and so at that point do you
just hope that you land at the exact
right kind of timing or is the ramp
built so that
you could kind of as long as you're
coming you can come in at a lot of
different angles in length yeah so it's
kind of you like obviously the ramp is
like 50 of the trick you know because
it's like you gotta have the same the
right trajectory if you're coming into a
flat surface you're just going to
explode so you need to like it's almost
like a plane you know it comes into line
just smooth like that so it's like when
we land we want to be landing in the
trajectory of the landing so that's like
smoother but it's still a hard landing
so all the places where you land usually
it has to be at an angle so that yeah
yeah because you couldn't just do it
flat
no not not safely you know i
there's like a certain level yeah and
once you pass that level your bones
can't do it yeah
that's that [ __ ] homemade halloween
baby you know
damn bro that's crazy man so um okay so
take me through some of this so you
start to get are you in school at this
point yeah yeah so i started so whenever
you kind of you kind of get going you
get on the scooter right yeah and is
scooter frowned upon i mean scooter like
you see somebody on a scooter like yeah
yeah you don't think like oh look at
this guy yeah i think and and that's
kind of a cool thing when i'm doing
these nice stickers tours because like
especially here in america they're like
they're like are you gonna take that
scooter down that ramp and i'm like bro
i'm gonna do way more than just take it
down the ramp
but yeah when i first started obviously
scootering was like it was just it was
just fun man and uh we did get it was
like
skateboarders would be like why are you
riding a scooter you're not gonna get
anywhere riding a scooter dude i'm like
well i'm just having fun man i'm not
really trying to get anywhere i'm just
trying to get to the skate park and do
some stunts but yeah i got heaps of um
grief for that like bullied obviously
but was there a lot of people scootering
were more people starting to do it yeah
yeah and it was like blowing up right
and i was like on the forefront of that
and then it's kind of like that's why
it i got to catch this wave of like
new age scooter dudes right and the
these tricks weren't created yet so i
was like in the forefront and i could
create tricks because
like the tricks that i was doing 10
years ago
100 like 10 000 kids can do it now
whereas it was like a world's first 10
years ago it was like being at the front
of like
it was like buying bitcoin you know it
was like it was like being at the
forefront like people were like whoa
looking at like bitcoin and then like
the dudes that did were like yeah now so
it's like that's what i'm doing it's
like i got on that first wave of
scooters and then now i'm here like yeah
that's crazy
okay i see man wow did you um
and did you just feel like did you try
skateboarding as well did you try other
things in the beginning and you just
felt most capable with the scooter or
what makes you stay with that yeah i
think that the biggest thing was just my
mates did it you know and i just want to
hang out with all my friends and like if
all my mates skateboarded i probably
would have been a skateboarder i
probably would have went that direction
because i did have a skateboard and i
would skateboard when my mate
skateboarded i would ride a bmx when my
mates wrote a bmx and that was kind of
the thing i would go to the skatepark i
was like i don't know i was like a
treasure trove of action sports i would
just bring like everything i could to
the skatepark just in case like more
people were doing that was like okay
it's time for the skateboard today right
and then i would just
um do that and that's kind of like why i
picked up scooter and so much just
because dude my mates are doing it and
it was just the coolest vibe to go down
the skate park have your mates learn new
tricks and then [ __ ] it yeah yeah yeah
so that's why i stick with the scooter
even though i got a lot of grief for it
yeah
and um and at school so it was just you
were you an only child yeah oh really
yeah oh wow yeah and so and you're did
was your mom like supportive of you
doing this kind of stuff or did she
think it was dangerous or was she kind
of a rebel what was she like my mom so i
did i raced bmx like on the dirt track
like just racing like when i was like
younger than when i roll about it or at
the same time because my mum was like
best in queensland at racing bmx when
she was young she was like number one in
queensland and then she started when i
started again when she was like 30 and
then she was number one again so really
yeah my mom's my mom's crazy bring up a
picture of her again what's her name oh
i got the best one you do i got a best
video search um mother verse
mega ant mum versus mega ramp i got my
mum to hit my mega grant no way yeah
swear i don't know what a mega ramp is
but i believe you i believe you i want
to i want to know more about it just
type in um oh yeah mom
oh yeah that one it's that one there
and then you're gonna have to skip in a
little bit
uh yeah yeah go back that's it go back
no no no a little bit further
what actually what's your name
backpack sorry my mom's name is donna
look here we go see she doesn't look
that bad in a helmet who's on the back i
know she's dimed up that's my that's my
gecko
look at her go
going
she's had three beers too
yeah yes yes man
that australian breakfast dude yeah
are you crazy
see you could do that
legend oh i could do that definitely
dude
i could definitely do that yeah donna's
throwing up [ __ ] signs dude the best
thing is she did it she did it again
like she was like that was it but she
was like i didn't go fast enough i want
to go higher yeah
so this is in your backyard at home yeah
yeah this is uh i just bought this land
it's called our willy land it's like an
action sports paradise for myself and i
just been like building ramps and uh
yeah just progressing action sports now
how so
okay a couple things here so how um
how
how
how big is this uh our willy land uh
it's uh 40 acres okay but it used
because it used to be a mango farm oh
yeah they still got mangoes out there
yeah they just fall off the tree like
i'll be walking up to go to a trigger
mango just fall off and i'll just pick
it up oh australia
god it sounds good so good
oh come for the freaking dangerous
animal stay for the free fruit man
um
so you got this park and now how much
does this park kind of cost to that that
kind of space yeah so um i mean the
land's like
over half a million for the land but
that's like
you know it's like that everywhere so
it's like that's general but the ramp is
like
5 000 and then for that big air bag
thing like it's a bag jump and that
thing's like
cost me
like close to 50 grand wow yeah but then
i've got another one that's like a
landing so like you switch you go from
that that is what i practice my tricks
on and like you can land on like your
head and be kind of all right
and then um once you get you tricked out
you switch it to the landing and then
you can like fully land the trick you
know like
claim the the new trick you know okay so
you would then move that out of that
space and put the ramp in that you know
you can land on yeah exactly wow is that
a crazy day oh man it is like it's i've
had it for like a year and a half now
and it's just insane because the best
thing is i have my mates from the
skatepark obviously i got great
opportunity with nitro circus you know i
got to ride these ramps and go to these
places and like progress myself but my
mates obviously stuck at home they
didn't have anything like that so now
it's so funny to see the mates that i
grew up with like 10 years ago that
would just ride in the skatepark now
they're riding like this mega ram of
mine and doing tricks that like no one
else has done as well so they're
progressing and becoming the best writer
they can be because i've got it and it's
it's a trip as well because i get like
young scooter kids like 10 year old kids
coming in and doing double backflips and
i'm like what is even going on i was
like
i don't even know what i was doing when
i was 10. you're gonna see yeah like
they're passing you it's like oh yeah
yeah it's like it's i'm sure it's
interesting to be a part of the um kind
of the movement in a way
um
okay so you get to this nitro circuit
let's go back and yeah a little so you
get onto this thing where you're going
now you're going to go tour in america
yeah so
you got to sign the video you've had
some videos that got out and you got
signed by nitrous circus yeah so i did
uh i got some of my nitro circus and the
first one was actually in australia and
it was just like
some company scooter heart they had paid
to like do advertising there and then
nitro sex was like oh who who are some
scooter kids like up and coming scooter
kids that can come jump this ramp and i
was one of them and i just
on my first show i did like a world's
first double front flip on scooter and
then from then on it was like i was just
on and it was just
it was mind-blowing i was like oh like
this is insane and did you
so at this point do you have like a
girlfriend already at this point do you
have like yeah i think i did have a
girlfriend i was because i was in school
in that and um yeah and like obviously
traveling and stuff it was hard but that
this is like when i'm 17. so it was like
a school a school girlfriend you know
right and were you like were you were
you becoming like a lot of pretty
popular in your area and stuff like that
oh yeah yeah definitely at the skate
park and like at school people knew i
was like fly i literally was doing
school monday to friday and then flying
out and doing a nitrous like a show and
then flying home you know and doing
schooling so it was like a trip
but yeah i was kind of a nerd in school
too so i finished school and got into
university but i didn't choose to do
that now in australia do you have to go
to university you don't have to no you
can like drop out you can drop out early
i could have already been out of school
when i was doing nitro circus and just
being like a laborer right but
you can go to yeah
it's pretty it's like pretty
well we're sick yeah
it's so good man okay so then you get on
this tour and you guys start to come to
america is your mom like stoked for you
is she disappointed like is she bummed
that you're leaving like what are some
of her thoughts yeah um
she was like obviously she was worried
at the start you know it's like i'm
risking my life kind of and like i could
get really hurt so yeah you're [ __ ]
around on a scooter
yeah yeah there's always until you make
it yeah and it's really professional
yeah whatever any child i think is doing
for their parent the parents always like
you're what the [ __ ] you know you're
[ __ ] around you know i want you to do
well but you're [ __ ] around here yeah
yeah for sure but until you really start
to do well and then she like gains she
obviously gained confidence in myself
and yeah uh i was pretty lucky with
injury and just like being calculated
and not just like throwing myself out
there because that's always been the
biggest thing it's like we're not dead
it was like we are in a way but we're
all i'm like calculating the risk it's
like is it worth doing this is the
reward worth it yes okay send it oops
broke my leg
but it was worth it yeah but yeah um so
i was uh i got a nice circus and then
that's kind of when things started to
really blow up for me and that's like
when i started to really get a name and
then that just made me more stoked to be
writing and like do better because i was
like man me having fun doing these
tricks that i love doing is like
progressing me through life this is like
a trip yeah
it is crazy when like your dream or
something that you're really putting
energy into that the world kind of meets
that
like like starts to like kind of push
that forward you're like what this is
crazy like why me like why do i get to
have this
like um
this
why does why do i get to be met this way
by
the flow of life you know i think
honestly a huge thing for me too was
the fact that you did get i did get
grief for riding a scooter you know i
got bullied for riding a scooter by like
yeah other people was better oh probably
dude if i drove by i yelled something
but then that was like that's like sick
like whatever i just took it right on
the chin and was like i'mma be so good
that you can't not be impressed that
that was like that was it that's like
was my driving force like my fire in my
belly was like all right so you think
that this is so bad that you can't be
cool well i'm gonna be so good that you
start to think it's cool right that you
can't help but think it's good yeah yeah
there's something nice about them wow
that's crazy you have that that desire
to be [ __ ] undeniable that desire to
like
prove people wrong even if it's just a
general yeah not even an exact person
but a general people um
and so and what about your mom does she
get remarried she got she got a man or
no yeah yeah she is now but that was a
while into it it's funny so my mom
worked at a stray zoo i don't know if
you've ever heard of australia zoo yeah
i might have been over there i can't
remember you the one where you get to
hold the um the koala yeah the koalas
and everything they got all the birds
yeah yeah yeah they got a gang gang bird
over there actually yeah so she
worked there and then um met the tiger
the tiger handler and like yeah and then
now she's married to the tiger handler
damn he's petting that cat boy that's
insane dude sorry i know that's your mom
no that's chilling but that's you know
that's how it works that's really that's
god bro
um she actually lives at my house today
so she does yeah so it's pretty cool
yeah well because so what happened was i
was when i was growing up obviously it
was hard for my mom and then um and your
dad was just gone he just was no he
wasn't gone he was like
he was just in a different state and it
was just like i thought it was it was
actually kind of cool because like i
didn't really know what was going like i
was so young it was like cool i get to
go on holidays i get to go down there
and like ride different skate parks sick
right so
yeah so that wasn't like it was fine my
dad and i see my dad here and there and
i s my dad actually lives at the land
now so my dad my dad lives at the land
where and because he's an excavator
driver so i like employed him basically
to be the groundskeeper
right and then my mum lives at my house
that i live in like that's crazy that's
a trip so now they're almost all back on
the same area yeah yeah kind of yeah but
my mom stays away from me yeah yeah yeah
well she got what she needed out of her
yeah yeah
okay so once you get on some of these
tours right so you get on are you on the
tours when you start to get onto some of
these nitrous circus right yeah is that
who's on these types of tours what types
of people is it oh yeah is it like a
carnival kind of like does it have that
vibe or at that time what was the vibe
like of it like was it really it was it
was pretty intense it was pretty gnarly
like when i first got on it was
it was like i don't know if you've ever
heard of the metal militia yeah that's
awesome that's right
uh yeah brian deegan yeah yeah yeah i
spoke with them yesterday actually no
way yeah actually i called him i was
like hey tell me about this our willy
guy i was like you know just let me know
a little bit more you know but he said a
lot of nice things man yeah so they were
like
back in the day they were like pretty
gnarly so when i got on they were going
straight from like metal there was a few
metal militia guys on nitro circus but
nitrous circus was like steered towards
it was also it also had that like
gnarliness but it also had like the
family vibe like we had funny like
contraptions like we would literally we
still have it it's like we would have
this with wheels on it and it jumps the
rant oh that's cool so it was like there
was that kid vibe as well like the
family vibe but so there really is like
a circus vibe to it in a way yeah yeah
kind of like a family circus like um
action sports vibe thanks bro
yeah cause the sir when i was a kid you
know what came to town sometime was the
circus barnums and bailey
two men i think one of them is a black
dude i don't know you never saw them men
but one of them had like a whip or
something yeah but they came to town and
they would have like the tent you know
and they'd have the guy who would swing
and you know he would do a flip and then
catch the other bar and like then he
would light him on fire or something
swinging back they'd have an elephant
somebody do a back flip off an elephant
um
so you had like that was a that was like
a circus you know that was like a circus
that came to town they didn't have like
the crazy trick so but it was like a
rout was like ours is like a rowdy
circus because it was like these guys
are just like mischief so a lot of them
were like just mischiefs and then like
now we're in the limelight like the when
i first got on it was it was pretty
crazy like the after parties were pretty
gnarly and i'm 17 years old damn so were
you going to these places is this some
of the first time you drank and stuff
you've been drinking with your mates and
stuff yeah i drank the i drunk a little
bit like in australia you drink pretty
young which is kind of like yeah yeah
you guys do everything dude yeah
when you guys get quick when you guys
die you're like i've done it yeah yeah
yeah for sure you guys get the most out
of the world it seems like yeah for sure
but um so yeah it was super it was
pretty wild so you can you drink and
stuff at these parties afterwards are
you like it's pretty cool yeah yeah it
was chill like and because it was nitro
circus like
i would be able to drink and go out and
it was cool and it was just like wild
because these dudes were like
superstars and i was just like the
scooter kid it was actually kind of
funny
when i first got on nitro circus they
were like we want him out of our
skateparks we're going to let him jump
the ramp hopefully he crashes and like
hurts himself kind of deal like they
wanted me i was like a sideshow at the
start
i was like the side show so i was like
but i didn't care i was 17 years old
like oh my god this is crazy and are you
guys you guys are on you're going on
tour buses what are you guys on um we
would fly but we also would do a tour
buses sometime but that was like when we
did europe tour so that was a little bit
later maybe two or three years into
doing the touring okay that's when we
got on the bus so you guys pull in like
a venue and it's like um is it outdoors
is it in stadiums like what kind of
venues are we talking what is it we've
done both so we did we did like um the
staples center we've done madison square
gardens and that yeah that as well
that's when we do like a bus tour and
it's a trip because you do this massive
show like in front of ten thousand plus
people you party go to sleep on the bus
wake up in a different like state yeah
and then do it again yeah like three
sometimes three nights in a row damn bro
yeah yeah i just gotta we just got a
tour of us or we're getting our first
one starting this week
uh
next week or something yeah so i'm
excited to have like a little bit of a
change of pace yes but yeah that thing
where you like leave late at night and
you just wake up and you're somewhere
else that's pretty cool
especially in europe it's like a trip
because i wake up in a different country
and it's like totally different you're
like what is going on it's like you had
like a weird dream and now you've tried
time traveled so had you finished school
so you're out doing this thing are you
graduating or no yeah so i just passed
schooling like primary uh high schooling
right and then uh and is it just like
chris lilly like in that show like in uh
in um
uh what's that show called
oh chris lilly
you know he's like miss
look oh yeah yeah yeah um summer heights
high yeah somehow is it really like that
over there you know what it's kind of it
kind of is like it's not even a bad
representation yeah it's awesome yeah
i love that dude that was one of the
best things when i
tour in australia i got to meet chris
lilly and that was pretty cool yeah he's
a legend oh dude unprecedented that that
show over in australia that's like
that's like one of the best shows yeah
everyone knows it's like a lot of people
here still don't know you chris have you
ever seen summer heights high
wow
you gotta watch it bro when somebody
hasn't seen it i get so jealous because
their life's gonna be so much better
it'll ch bro if your relationship's bad
sit down and watch that together i'll
watch it
there you go yeah
perfect very very very
good answer there um okay so you're on
this tour you guys are doing this tour
you're like going to different cities
and stuff and that's in the u.s right
yeah it's your first time in the u.s u.s
and europe um
i did do like a little scooter trip like
when i was really young for the us but
the biggest like the actual tours and
the full-on experiencing the usa yeah it
was on nitrous circus tours on a bus and
and flying a lot has anybody ever paid
you to like a private party or something
like that like uh um i've done like cool
camps for kids and like done like um in
canada i went to this all in skatepark
and like just spent a week with kids and
taught them it's pretty crazy actually
uh
i was filming youtube videos and these
kids were just so stoked that i would
like get so much content because these
kids would just send themselves and like
yeah i got some i got some wild clips of
these kids just sending it you know
really yeah
is this is are there times where you do
you ever meet a kid you're like oh that
kid's gonna die you know
yeah
yeah that's great yeah there's a few but
if you're like i'm like oh i think i'm
wild but these these kids dude you gotta
get a mark and put a little star on
their shoulder or something you know i'm
saying just so yeah just watch out keep
tabs yeah yeah yeah
um
all right so once you really get to once
you like at this point your career is
going like are you
are they paying you like what is that
whole process like yeah so obviously
when i first got on nitro it was like i
i was 17 years old so i was it was great
money for then right happy to be there
yeah yeah oh yeah they give you a
thousand bucks a week you're like this
is amazing but then i think about three
years in that's when i was like making a
living you know or not even that
actually probably probably a year after
starting with nitro then i was like okay
i can literally do this for a job wow
yeah and then eventually
like i bought my first house when i was
21. damn and then yeah and then just
kept going from there like crazy to ride
a scooter and then like to make such a
good living it's just it's a trip yeah
one thing i noticed about you even in
watching some of your own uh
podcast clips and stuff is just like
your enthusiasm
and like you're kind of like
just your excitement that this is your
life you know
like sometimes i embrace that stuff like
kind of cautiously like i'm almost
not ashamed of my life but sometimes i
get embarrassed that i make money or
embarrass that
you know have like
you know you seem to just kind of wear
it just kind of more like excited like i
can't believe i get to do this and this
is it yeah well i always just want to be
out of like i want to show like i want
to i want people to see that like you
can be a 12 year old scooter kid down
the skate park like literally
you can be that kid and then make a
living out of it when no one really like
ever thought you would yeah so it's like
you can pave your own path it doesn't
matter if the path isn't there yet
you can make your own path
and then like that's why i'm like so
stoked i'm like right dude i'm here like
with you on your podcast and i've been
i've watched you for so long yeah and
then now i'm here and the reason i'm
here is just because
i'm so stoked to be riding a scooter and
i i literally am here because i didn't
listen to the person that told me that i
couldn't do anything riding a scooter
right you know if i listen to that
person go
mate you're not going to do anything
right as good all the the thousands of
people that told me that actually if i
listen to even one of those people i
wouldn't be sitting here today right so
stoked with my life so it's like i just
want to inspire people to just keep
put pushing on and believing in whatever
you're doing it doesn't matter yeah
yeah no that's a unique gift you have
man because yeah it's like you make me
more stoked to be here today like i like
showed up dude and i was like excited
you know because i'm a fan and i wanted
to learn i want to learn about you know
what you do and what goes into it and
stuff but then when i see you it's like
you're so excited i'm like
[ __ ] now i have to be more excited
because i have to meet you at a certain
level of excitement um where do you get
that from do you think you get that from
one of your folks actually
yeah i don't know actually um the people
around me like travis pastrana was a
huge inspiration to me and it wasn't
just because of the things that he's
done like he's done amazing things
incredible things but and he's done
things that um other people could maybe
do now but the thing is
that inspires me about travis astronaut
is the fact that he can bring the best
out of the people around him
when he the funniest thing we're on tour
right now with nitro circus and
we we're doing the show and he's not at
the shows and then he turned up for one
show and that show was like the best
show we did because of the energy that
he brings and just the level he just
lifts you to a new level like just with
his presence yeah and like that's what
inspires me that's what i'm trying to
reach now it's like
can i
be that guy that when this good kids
like when the scooter kids around me bmx
kids around me they
just get that little extra like boost
you know let's see how he can do he's
here yeah how can i be that guy that is
the cool i think that is like the
coolest thing about travis astronaut and
that's like what inspires me to
just be stoked yeah for many people in
the u.s of america concerned about the
cost of health insurance there are no
good options there's none
zilcho
but crowd health is a community of
people who are tired of paying for a
broken system
yep it's a place where you can get a
simple flexible and affordable way to
pay for your health care
crowd health is able to offer amazing
prices because of its community of
health conscious members
for a limited time our listeners get
their first month free
and after you've been a member crowd
health will include a fitness wearable
that's 30 days
to try risk-free plus the fitness
wearable just go to crowdhealth.com
fit
and enter code theo at sign up enter
that code baby you want to get that
crowd health you want everybody helping
you breathing into your lungs you want
that cpr
you want that damn uh
heimlich you want it all
and that's crowdhealth.com
fit
promo code theo yup crowd health is not
health insurance it's a
community-powered alternative terms and
conditions apply if you're sick of big
health insurance
and the bs that goes with it
go to crowd health
go to join crowdhealth.com fit and enter
code theo learn about it crowd health
look it's tough when you're looking for
insurance online it's aggravating you
don't want to do it
it feels overwhelming a lot of times it
feels like too much
that's what i've noticed
well
times have changed
thanks to the zebra
the zebra
it's that striped sneaky prison looking
animal
yup you can compare car and home
insurance quotes from every major
insurance company in under five minutes
giving you all the facts you need to
make the right decision in fact the
zebra saves people an average of 922
dollars a year on home and auto combined
it's a lot of money it's an extra g
get yourself a swing set or get
something for the children
get a teeter totter for your daddy
yep the zebras help me it can help you
compare quotes for free at the zebra.com
t-h-e-o and support the podcast that's
at the zebra.com
slash theo save time and money in
minutes on your home and auto insurance
what gifts does what does pastrana have
that makes him that
that
gives him that ability you think or what
is it about him it's the thing it's how
great he is right and the
accomplishments that he's done right so
he has his work that he's yeah yeah but
he's so he's so good he is like up there
you know like he's a everyone kind of
knows him yeah it's like he's like a
tony hawk as well like he's that level
and you know you hol you like think okay
he's that level like he probably doesn't
have that much time but he does for
everybody he's like everyone's best
friend and that was the trippiest thing
for me when i got on nitro circus was
the first show i'm on this scooter kid
and i do this well first and i remember
after i did it i was like so stoked but
the biggest thing i remember from that
day is riding back to the the start ramp
and travis high fived me and gone dude
that was sick like that was so cool and
i was like wow
i was like wow like this is insane that
this guy that i
hold up like this like i've held up
inspired me to even start
for him to just give me
that it was like it was like a a year's
worth of excitement in one second wow
yeah yeah it's so amazing man when you
have like somebody that you really
idolize or you really put on a pedestal
and they have a little bit of time for
you or they have like an encouragement
that really helps you know man the power
of that is almost unprecedented really i
think i think that and i always keep
that in mind because we obviously do
these nitro sega shows and it's like
there's thousands of people there and
like
kids will want to come get a photo take
a picture get an autograph it's like and
that's what i always remember i always
remember like
five seconds of travis pastrana's time
was like a year's worth of just
excitement for me so it's like if i can
give a kid five seconds of my time and
that it means that much to him i'm gonna
give that kid that five seconds every
single time you know yeah keeps you
stoked and so y'all show so so you said
you hit a first trick and that was on
one of the nitrouses on one of the yeah
yeah so it was just it was a double
front flip on scooter and like no one
had ever tried it and what you did we
saw earlier was a triple triple yeah so
yeah so that evolved obviously into that
triple yeah and did you start to when
you got on the tour um
prepping for that trick you'd already
done it in practice
um i had tried so when i first got on
the show i tried it in practice and
crashed it twice okay so that's what
made the moment so special is that like
it was my first show i'm obviously like
it's so excited like and so nervous but
to ace that trick it was like it was
like something happened like it was like
the trajectory of my life just went
damn and i was like okay i'm i'm doing
it wow
damn
you must feel like there's like a higher
power or something that has a hand in
that when you because it just the
science and everything to like
flip off of something and just have it
be perfect in a moment where it's like
in a real show yeah well that's i think
that that's where i've done really well
like i never think that i'm someone that
is physically built better or like wired
better than anybody else i think i just
managed to
like succeed when it's most important
it's like at x games it's like i need to
do land this trick now and then i'll
just land it you know
but
i i obviously do the preparation but for
some reason it's just sick to
in moments of when i need to do it i got
it done and i think that's the main
reason why i got to where i am today and
it's like
it's
it's a gift i mean it's yeah it almost
feels like you're favored
in some sense yeah i would ever say and
i just thank
whatever the driving force is thank you
and i try to thank it every day and i
try to give back like my positivity to
the people around me because maybe
that'll turn their trajectory you know
maybe that'll do you know that one
moment might change their life and they
might do something
better and be better in the end you know
so yeah
no man it's inspiring even sitting with
you makes me feel a little bit better
than when i wasn't sitting with you
thanks and to be honest i think
you got to give yourself some
appreciation too i think that you i mean
you probably realize like i'm sure a lot
of people like ride in and tell you how
like happy you make their lives and i'm
sure you you make people's day so like
much better just by listening to your
talk and i think that's
amazing and i think that's that's why
you deserve to be paid for what you do
and like you work hard so it's like
you deserve it i think yeah yeah it's
funny sometimes i have a tough time
thinking that i deserve things you know
and i don't know where that comes from i
think it comes from
i don't know i i'm trying to find you
just gotta find it yeah yeah yeah it's
another try to it takes a while
sometimes to find things like that when
you're really trying to figure out where
they're from you know yeah for sure but
yeah i've always struggled feeling like
i deserve stuff you know um but that's
okay i hope to be able to figure it out
and i'm sure that i will
yeah
what uh so you get in so when do you
when do you get into
like
like at some point you won you won a
couple of competitions right i know i
read this but
um and deegan was talking with me about
it but
uh
so what happened like that was kind of
like another thing that changed
yeah so they um the shows are huge and
then they had a thing called nitro world
games and it was like a competition now
so they changed the the show
changed into a competition that was
obviously the x games right and that was
a huge one that i wanted to do but
obviously i was like a scooter rider and
a bmx rider at a certain point it's a
funny funny story actually so i rode bmx
at the skatepark here and there but it
wasn't like my profession right right
and then at nitro circus
i was doing tricks on a scooter that had
never been done on a bmx bike
so wait hold on so you're doing tricks
on a scooter
that's never been done on a bmx yeah yes
okay you can do the same you can do the
same tricks obviously just a different
vehicle but so i was doing tricks that i
could do on a scooter that no one had
ever never done on bmx and so did
someone challenge you to do it on the
bmx that's it they were like the only
reason you can do this is because you're
on a scooter and i was like you know
what i reckon that's not true
and i ended up borrowing one of their
bikes like one of the other guys on two
i borrowed their bike and i did the
trick first i think i was like first try
did it and then
that's when like i was like
here we go x games dream i can reach it
like all i have to do is bring these
scooter tricks over to the bmx world
because no one's doing it for some
reason because they think it's lame or
something right and i'm like oh well
i don't mind i'll just do the lame
tricks then
i'll just be the lame legend yeah sorry
if you need me i'll be in lame land
right here yeah drinking lemonade baby
i'll be up there dog damn
that's beautiful dude so now at that
point did you win that thing yeah so i
won the nitro world games um the first
year it happened i actually lost on the
scooter competition and won the bmx
competition which was kind of hilarious
and then came back the next year and i
won scooter and bmx yeah and then i
think it was like the year after i
finally got on x games and then
yeah i've won three x games gold's now
has anybody won three x games gold or no
so
yeah people have won like travis has won
so many i think he's got like some of
the most but like that's they're up like
in the 20s you know but that i think so
i did accomplish something recently
i uh won the i was the first person to
do three golds in a row
in on the mega ant so if for some reason
for 20 years it had never happened that
a person had consecutively won three
gold medals in a row on the mega ramp
and it made me so nervous because i was
coming to the i was coming into the
third one like oh here we go like time
just kept repeating itself i think like
five people before me had won it twice
and then they lost this the third time
so i was like here we go so the third
time do is that is there a video there
yeah um you go
uh
x games ryan williams x games
um
[Music]
2018 i think
on 19.
try
i'll tell you straight away nah nah go
go 19.
not that one the
uh that one the real cost big air but
it's a full broadcast go go the second
you go to the next one down
yeah try that one real quick
wow that's so hot
so this isn't my winning run but you'll
see like
wait is this it no this is if i crash
it's not it
no
no uh
that doesn't
keep skipping in sorry oh hang on this
is going to play all of them this is
good this is good actually
so keep it rolling um
so that was this is the first time i won
and this was in australia so my first
time ever won x games was in australia
my whole family there i i paid for
everyone to fly down and stay there and
it was oh it was like so incredible
because that was like my dream achieved
you know a gold medal at the x games oh
man it's it's not this one though go
back to
go back to the
the search click the dude you have at
that point you have the haircut of every
i feel like kind of middle-aged woman in
the town that i'm from a little bit
honestly
at that point dude i know i had to i had
to dial it back dude i don't know what i
was doing yeah you were going big dude
but you had a total k it was like a real
caring kind of haircut i feel like at
that point it's hard to beautiful though
very nice try the
try the second one
i really want to show you this one
because this is i had yeah this is it
this is it this is it i had to do the
craziest thing at the start this was the
gnarliest thing i've ever done i've
never done a backflip drop-in and
wow yes and then i know he missed up the
ramp i wrote up like
the tiniest part of the rant and then
i'm like here i'm like oh gosh i gotta
land this guy in this gotta land that's
gonna land that's gonna land this did it
oh man and it was
it was such a trip because everyone was
doing so well yeah i was i was stoked
wow
can we go back once it'll it'll be a
slow-mo replay i think yeah yeah
yeah look how stoked you are man you
gotta carry your own bike down well do
you think someone's gonna run up and
just bring it down at that point yeah it
sounds sort of concierge yeah you can
see
so you've never done that no and what
made you do that can we just pause it
right there i want to win the third row
dude i have oh so you're thinking what
can i do that'll be different i need to
do it yeah not like guys are doing
tricks into it morgan wade he like did a
double tail whip into it and like guys
are 360 into it so they were stepping it
up and i knew that i had to do something
that like had never been done before to
get the win like they weren't going to
give it to me easily so i was just like
i have to just do this did you feel like
you had extra pressure to try and get
away like they were going to judge you
even more harsh because you already had
two in a row like it's a little bit
tougher to get the third one yeah i had
to i had to send it like i wasn't
holding back and i i would have just
done it anyway like even if i like in
the moment it was for dave dave mirror
so
he he passed away recently and um yeah
and he actually the was the first guy i
ever seen do a backflip drop in so i was
like when i'm at the top i'm actually
like this is for you dave oh this is for
you mira as i'm at the top and then i
just hacked it man and it was crazy like
it's like moments like this the moments
like this is the it just trips me out
and then i nearly wrote off the side of
the ramp going like this is obviously
one of my it was one of my signature
tricks that i brought from the scooter
world right
wow so there you go
that's called a nothing front bike flip
of course it is
or two we twisted the the
inside joke until that and then here so
you lean that energy forward kind of but
not yep all the way no i have to be
really light though right because that
ramp's 27 and a half foot tall so it's
like if you it come off at all like you
are hurting yourself real bad
yeah so
here's a trip man
so what and where do they measure the uh
the ramps from where do they measure
that 27 feet where do they start that so
from the where it starts to go up so
from the bottom of the ramp to the
coping which is the metal like part
across that's like 27.5 foot and i think
it's like there's some two foot of it or
something so vert is just straight up
okay
and so uh
when you
when you
get to like the peak of the ramp right
you have to be careful not to drift
forward well literally oh you don't yeah
you don't know for it's real it's harder
to go into the ramp than it is it's easy
to come out like the thing okay i could
that's the scariest part about that ramp
is you're going so fast that literally
if i went like this
if i went like that right i would go
16 i would go so far out the flat that
would break my legs jesus damn bro so
that's why in that moment man i am like
that is the most wide i've ever been in
my life is when i'm doing that i'm like
if i don't do the right thing right now
i'm gonna get really really hurt okay so
you're going up you're heading up the
ramp what is the right thing at that
point like what's the right amount of
so i'll i'll go up it's just it's kind
of like
it's like the riding with your eyes
closed you get built it gets built into
you yeah like i know that this will do
this right so it's like i remember i
just i just remembered that i'd done i'd
landed the that trick before the the
front flip one so i knew okay this is
what i have to do
i'm going really fast but
i just got to like chill it's almost
like i just float off the ramp so i
wrote up and i just go to like i don't i
don't want to initiate it's not like the
triple front flip total opposite right
you're not trying to just initiate a lot
of i'm lucky i'm like this like
literally i'll pretend i'm doing it
right now i'm going out and i'll go like
this
like that like that
and then you just
and then you just hold on baby you're on
the roller coaster with no you're not
strapped in is your eyes open or not
yeah eyes are wide open
but you don't at the start it's kind of
blind because i'm looking at the sky you
know i'm not looking at the ground and
then i'll be looking at the ground
that's kind of the scariest part of that
trick okay because
for a second off for a second i'm like
am i out am i on top of the ramp or am i
perfectly transitioned into coming in
and i like look you can see like i so i
go oh and then i see i'm blind see i'm
like looking at i was looking at the
roof for a bit and then all of a sudden
as i'm coming down i look okay now i'm
coming in i'm not landing flat i'm not
hitting the top of the ramp i'm coming
in smooth that would be and that's
that's the fear that's the moment when
you're like i'm gonna land it this way
wow yeah because i've already played it
through the simulator right yeah and i'm
like this is what i'm expecting to see
and then that moment i seen that
there we go let's roll away damn bro
that's fire
wow
i wish i know how to do something like
that
well whenever i come to queensland dude
i'm gonna have to go to our willy uh to
our willy land yeah and go on uh
and do something through the truck dude
i'll keep the trucks there for you my
mom's try no i need something better
than that oh yeah okay i think so dude
yeah look
the trike look oh all respect to your
mom you know all respect to donovan she
obviously
[ __ ] has done her work you know but
i think what's next up from a trikey
thing
oh that'd be a bmx bike could someone
handle that or not is that yeah like a
mountain bike it's kind of pretty sturdy
okay and you just go off it really hurt
a bike huh that's what i was gonna ask
you have you ever done an extreme sport
um like skateboarding or anything like
rolled around
a lot of skateboarders boss just really
were just doing drugs you know they
owned the boards but there was mostly
just for you know setting their drugs on
while they would roll them up
but we didn't have a lot of i'm trying
to think if we had extreme sports bus
yeah we had these guys that used to
shoot these potato gun like uh
they had like a rest area bus i don't
know if they have it on and maybe in
australia your whole country is like a
rest area actually but it's like a rest
area is like a place where you stop on
the side of the interstate when you're
driving yeah yeah and people like uh get
out to use the restroom and drink water
change the baby you know
you usually have a cigarette and then uh
get back in the van and keep going you
know sometimes beat the kids or whatever
but um if they've been bad yeah yeah but
not uh but anyway by us there was a
there was one of those and behind it
they had a river
and a lot of gay men would meet up at
these places because it was like a um
you know it was like on the outskirts of
town some gay men would meet up over
there and
you know do drugs and make out and stuff
yeah and
across the river that's where i lived so
a lot of men over there some would not a
lot but they had these two guys that
would make like potato these potato gun
launchers yeah and if like a lot of like
like real high men were making out or
something they would shoot potatoes over
near them oh no way pretty messed up i
mean they weren't trying to endanger
them or anything i think they just
didn't want to surprise them yeah i
think they just didn't want them doing a
lot of drugs and making out in the water
they didn't want anybody to drown
because some men had drowned okay so it
was almost like lifeguarding a little
bit but but that was like the most
extreme sport i ever saw was people with
these potato guns you know yeah um
i think anyway you've read a bike
yeah i rode a bike yeah but i never
really thought much of it we used to
build the ramp you know somebody always
liked the ramp like was a poorly built
and this part would come out and then
somebody the handlebar would turn and
went into some guy's body one time i
remember yeah but pretty [ __ ] we were
pretty pretty [ __ ] ex-gamers
oh well that's right but i think i could
probably get out there i would love to
get out there and try that would be sick
i could i could teach you like safely to
do it too yeah you say we could get you
flying yeah i think i'd be willing to
um so what is like that what does the
future of this whole sport kind of look
like like
what's what is a a mechanism like not
the bike or the scooter what's something
that came out that people thought was
going to be like the next thing that
people were going to use for tricks that
kind of didn't make it was there
have there been
kind of died off now like rollerblades
are like pretty big
back when i started doing it it was kind
of like still around and still in the x
games but then rollerblading's just
dropped off a fair bit but there's still
insane dudes doing the rollerblades
maybe like a rip stick i don't know like
that's kind of like you know what a rip
stick is the one where you people go
like this you get speed it's like one
wheel and it goes like that let's see
that can we pull that up a rip stick
it's kind of like a weird yeah
oh yeah you seen that thing i think i've
seen this i think that i think that you
might find this a bit like even worse
than uh rollerblading
yeah
i love it all
if you want to ride a ripstick man ride
a ripstir
yeah
actually it looks pretty fun actually
yeah
i think uh
yeah i'm trying to think we had like a
role a place called roller kingdom bus
where we'd have all our birthday parties
yeah and uh
dude this one kid
this kid jeremy who we were buddies with
at the birthday parties he would go and
get all the gum from like under the
tables and make a huge like and by the
end of the birthday party he would be
chewing the biggest gum dude he was
twisted bro that's crazy oh he was so
twisted dude he did it every [ __ ]
time bro
he just had this ultimate thing of gum
dude
and his nobody would even his parents i
guess weren't paying attention to him
because
when they came to pick him they wouldn't
even ask him he couldn't even open his
mouth one time he had so much [ __ ]
government he's just breathing through
his nose and his mom's like you're doing
great jeremy you know
so [ __ ] that's the next game right
now that's pretty yeah that's pretty
extreme yeah so that's it that's the
kind of extreme sports that we had
nice a bit more like that um
was there was there what about that the
motorized thing that i see with the one
wheel in the middle yeah that thing's
wild um i've seen some people lately
doing some pretty crazy jumps on that i
think things just keep evolving and like
there's so many crazy just sports just
people like ride a pogo stick
professionally yeah and i kind of think
that's like
i can't say anything like it's great
like i just appreciate it like whatever
if you if you find it fun man just just
do it but it's pretty wild that like you
can be a professional pogo sticker yeah
yeah i wonder if they could do like a
poker stick with like a wheel on it i
wonder if they could do
what about hilly's
you know healings yeah they dropped off
yeah they did drop you know there was
one
there used to be soap shoes they called
and they people literally would have
grime plates on their shoes and they
wouldn't and they would just run and
jump and grind downstairs that's one
that's 100 dropped off but people were
doing it
soap soap shoes
soap s-o-u-p yeah i think that's soup
soap s-o-a-p
yeah that's super so
you see any chris
i think i've seen some dudes do some
pretty
like gnarly rails on it yeah yeah so
that's mostly for rail slides and stuff
like that this is a full movie look at
this i think i've seen part of this it's
hilarious soap or die
ryan what
damn you didn't even know that there's
like there that'd be right i moved to
the uk and there he is here look this is
it see on the rail man
ah so the shoes have just like a place
in the middle plate wow
yeah this is one that didn't take off
well it it like i guess it had a time
for like a year and then i don't know
now i guess because once you land you
can't like then you just run i don't
know right i think they like run off
it's like that free running you know
yeah parkour yeah and that's that never
really took off but people still do it
and that's just kind of like just
running around yeah like it's like
practicing running away from like
yeah something yeah like i'm gonna trick
the cops or something or like it's
almost like athletic uh
a lot of parkour people i think are
athletic um
graffiti it's like it's like a little it
seems like a side like a
hustle yeah for graffiti people yeah
like i'm gonna paint this later but
watch first i'm going to run you know
i'm going to run around with this yeah
i feel like that could actually be
pretty cool if they're free running
incorporated with graffiti like they do
graffiti on the run
yeah i wonder if there's a way where
they as they went up like say they go up
a ramp right or a vert what does that
call it he has a rant a rant yeah so
then if they had a wall while they're up
there and like each time they went up
they had to paint something and then by
the end of like you know after six times
it going up then they had like a piece
of art up there
just trying to think do you see
something as being like the next thing
because something always kind of comes
along like you're saying it's like you
know a new mode of transportation comes
along and then that's what um
i don't know um like the thing you got a
cycle as a unicycle yeah people
literally do tricks on that i think
it's crazy these days anything can just
become something you know it's like
tick tock is now huge when five years
ago i didn't like i didn't even know
what that was yeah you know it's just
like the niche it's just something
happens and then it just sticks
they're just throwing [ __ ] at the wall
and then just sticks and like oh
everyone's like [ __ ] i want to throw
[ __ ] at that [ __ ] at the wall too yeah
why do australians why are you guys such
a practice facility for insane [ __ ]
it's out of you guys in new zealanders
it always is i feel like yeah i don't
know i guess it's in our heritage but um
i guess we've just all we're always just
being that kind of loose cannon vibe and
then it's just stuck like i'm super
proud to be australian and when i think
of an australian i think of like someone
that's just like outgoing gonna try
something like crazy yeah you know just
for no i don't even know why we just do
it it's like just built into us yes
blockovic is here he's in new zealand
block a [ __ ]
uh no he's the ufc guy you know what i'm
talking about yeah yeah jan blockovich
isn't he european he's european he was
new z i thought he was there's israel
out of sanya who's new yeah there's izzy
there's dan hooker who i love yeah rob
funny man robert whittaker australian oh
really
the guy that was a shooter yeah dude i
almost got to meet him at the uh poirier
fight yeah sick yeah he's a freaking
those guys are great is there um
do you feel like uh
do you feel like there's like a next
level for you do you feel like
do you ever feel like
you've kind of achieved all that you can
or what do you yeah yeah
sometimes actually that's one thing that
kind of gets to me sometimes is that
like why am i doing this you know you
like look around and
you you see like people that have like a
job that is caring like you care that
cares for someone or they look after
someone and you're like wow that like
really matters like you're a doctor that
like really really helps someone and
then sometimes i'm like well i'm just
here just spinning around doing circles
and like people like to watch it but
like what am i really bringing yeah and
that sometimes that gets to me because
i'm like why am i risking it myself to
just do these like stunts
when like what are they really achieving
but
they do it like people are inspired by
it to do anything they might even just
be inspired to like go harder in their
life and whatever they're doing so it's
like yeah and i'm sure you see kids that
remind you of yourself probably yeah 100
and that's why i like i'm always pushing
and the craziest thing is like the
tricks i'm doing
i was doing 10 years ago everyone's
doing now like so it's like i think the
same way like whatever i'm doing now
whatever i do to push the limits here
today
that's just gonna make action sports
even crazier like in the long run you
know it's just gonna level up action
sports so the harder i can go
the harder it's gonna like the crazier
it's gonna be in the future i think
is there a chance so you see sometimes
you would see like that man drops in
from outer space or something with the
red bull stuff you know the guy you know
danny whatever his name is he jumps off
of something and lands you know
is there a way that you could do like a
drop into a ramp but from like an
insanely high pla like off of a building
and then still hit the
like land it yeah yeah come in at a
certain place on the ramp where you
could still then go do something or
something yeah so there's that's crazy
like that i'd love to do something like
that i've always imagined like maybe
doing a trick like a world's first or
something new across two buildings or
something like that but
robbie madison is a guy that did
he jumped onto the luge i think or
something like i think it was just the
one in vegas though like the it's like
the building with the archway he like
jumped up it and then turned around and
then jumped off into iran wow yeah
robbie madison so
did he really can we look at that real
quick you
yeah it was wild
it's like and are there a lot of i feel
like there'd be a lot of vietnamese kids
doing this is there like a lot of asian
kids that do this sport do you notice
bmx is popping off in japan because they
just had the olympics and this like logo
shout out to logan martin he won the
olympic gold medal the first ever bmx
olympic gold medal oh because it was the
first time they ever had bmx in the
first time i had bmx first time out of
skateboarding yeah this is it
so he jumps up
right yeah which is gnarly so gnarly
and then he turns around he almost goes
too far
there's his hopefully it's his girl yeah
tripping out if not at somebody somebody
definitely is gonna try and get child
support i don't know that's for sure
just make it in the video wow can you
imagine looking down from here bro look
at that oh my god that makes my freaking
penis just go inside of my body dog dude
that's a that's funny that you say that
that sometimes i'm riding if i'm really
concentrating i can feel like my dick
shrinking
that's cool
i think it's like a defense mechanism oh
yeah your dick's like you might be doing
this i'm not
oh yeah they got her really really
scared they got oh he's up there looming
now do you feel like he's totally
confident at this point he's just kind
of this is for sure i mean it's just
he's just got to do it you got to be
confident if you're not confident it's
like that's where you're going to get
it's going to go wrong you have to have
100 belief in yourself jesus i could
never do that
i've never done that my whole life dude
yeah he's got it he goes too far too
nearly dies
oh yeah you see
like just catching the very bottom
bro that was lucky that was really close
do you think he made it that close on
purpose or not that was an accident that
was he he did not want to do that he
didn't want to go far because like
if he went i meet him more oh yeah
that's bad news bears yeah
like you're saying you got to come in
where there's enough of that yeah if you
don't catch the
transition yeah then you're
pancaking yeah do you feel pretty proud
of yourself a lot of times you able to
feel that kind of stuff
um
yeah when i when i achieve something
that i've really wanted to do for a long
time i'll feel that but that's just like
that's one problem that i have is just
it's like under the necks it's like you
it's hard to sit and smell the roses
when you just i'm just so passionate
about it and it's like why stop when i
don't have to or when i am able to just
keep going just
it's hard for me to sit back and go whoa
sick i'm rad yeah yeah yeah
yeah and maybe because i think at some
point in some ways there's not a ton of
value in it i think there's value in
like having appreciation for what you're
doing and like recognizing it yeah but
yeah to sit there and just smell the
roses you know you got to keep watering
them too so it's like
um i'll just always find that kind of
interesting uh is there a trick or
something you have your eyes kind of set
on is there like a new template or a new
like
mode or something you're trying that you
see yourself maybe being able to
like a new type of ramp is there things
that you think of sometimes that you
well obviously it'd be so cool to do
something like that like something out
there and just different not just a new
variation of a trick you know but
there's tricks that i have that i on my
trick list that i want to do that are
like going to be that really next level
like i want to do i really want to do a
a triple backflip 360. so
like so three flips with us with a spin
in it now when okay so say you're doing
that when do you start to incorporate
the spin so about i wouldn't nearly do
it at the very start but it's going to
be so i would do like a
a flip with a 180 turn and then a a flip
with a 180 turn and then the last one
would just be straight
ah i see so you would do a flip and a
one and then flip one and then just
straight oh interesting
yeah um when you guys go out on some of
these tours did is it is the partying
pretty good who parties better like
people on the on the uh on the nitro
circus tour or australians in general do
you think
probably um i mean australian's probably
so hard but i feel like everywhere
party's pretty hard like america these
get pretty wild like you've reached a
point where he's just going like go mad
but i think on tour it's so insane
because
we're all like super passionate you know
it's it's everyone is like at the
pinnacle of their sport action sport so
they're like
you know they're like the boss skate
like if you went to a skate park there's
that one kid that's like like insane and
then like if you hand pick like the best
ones join them into a group like a
circus and that's what you get like we
all are like
can't have adhd i guess well and we're
all just super passionate so so is there
a lot of partying as much as or do you
hear stories that used to be more
partying because with comedy you always
hear stories like people were doing
cocaine right here and now people are
doing their taxes you know what i'm
saying it's just like gotten hella
[ __ ] lame dude yeah it's it's changed
a lot for us too because i'm the
youngest on tour so and i'm 27. so
and you but it used to be like everyone
else's
20s like in their 20s 20 in their 30s
but now they all have families and like
kids so it's like mellowed out a lot but
in a way that's a good thing and a bad
thing because we're all like smarter
wiser doing making the right decisions
you know you're not getting drunk and
then potentially like riding the next
day hungover and hurting yourself yeah
but there's guys on tour that literally
will just
drink into oblivion then wake up and
just triple backflip and like like it's
nothing like that you have the rockstar
dude still doing that and
at moments that's the rockstar's still
there like yeah if you drink seeing
everyone's kind of a rock star again is
that your vibe really or no yeah
yes and no like i definitely love to
have fun go out and like party and i had
a few drinks at the laugh factory last
last night but yeah it would have been
weird for me to like go party and then
go do a show because i
i have a younger following too and i
want to be a hundred percent like when i
do a show i feel like a lot of people
i'm representing scootering i'm
representing action sports to like
families and kids just in terms of
representing scootering is so insane
it's so great though man it's so great
to think of something that yeah you
would see some like yeah you see some
kid on and you're like oh [ __ ] this kid
you know 10 years ago well that's it
like then now i'm sitting here enamored
by this kid you know so it's really
interesting man that was like my goal
ever since the start man i was like what
can i do like scootering literally gave
me my life like this amazing life so
right i give my life to scootering like
what could i do
to stop that kid at the skate park
getting
grief like i did yeah so he can just
enjoy it you know and just even though
it was probably a good thing for me
that's the thing that's i always wonder
it's like we all we want to stop all the
bullying but [ __ ] dude if i didn't get
bullied some dude i would not
that that's how you even get any gun
yeah so it's interesting but i know what
you're saying you want them to know that
there's an outlet you want to be yeah
available for inspiration and they're
always everyone's always it's always
going to be that bullying's always going
to be around it's just you've got to
harden yourself i got it so bad in
school like and then i got it so bad at
the skate park and it like almost built
this hard shell around my body that it
was like i don't like it bounces off me
right everything bounces off oh dude
i'll drive any playground i drive by
dude if i'm by myself i roll down the
window and yell a damn little slur or
something you know what i'm saying to
get somebody fired up yeah
something where somebody's out there
that it's like what is it is that about
me uh i better get my [ __ ] together
yeah for sure you gotta drop a little
something um
um
what is the next so say you took a
scooter yeah and you made it cool
what is something else that's kind of
shitty that you could take and make it
[ __ ] awesome bro
and if you guys have ideas in there too
chris let us know what is the next thing
that ryan could take
that is it's like a challenge
hypothetically not shitty and i
shouldn't have said that man that's kind
of an offensive way to say it but
but something that people would see i
couldn't see this being a mode to become
amazing yeah
i wonder what else is out there
i know it's kind of like um video gaming
as well that was kind of like a lot like
people like what professional video game
players
oh
bro yes
dude that travel what is that thing
called i have no clue chris what is that
thing suitcase scooter oh yeah
bro if you could do a something on that
and then open it and take something out
and maybe
i mean i'm just thinking can we what if
you do that thing where like sometimes
people want to be cool when they're
handicapped and they get that little
like knee thing that little uh oh yeah
yeah when they have a cast on yeah it's
like just use crotch as your [ __ ] man
use some crotches man i'm gonna have to
get that that'd be perfect for the the
airport just cruising around oh dude
especially to see you on it would be
legendary like what did that guy just do
did that dude just [ __ ] do a 670
through tsa
um
yeah what other can you pull that back
up that thing's pretty that was pretty
great actually oh
oh that thing we talked about that yeah
you see these things around what about
the lime scooters like they're
everywhere now yeah and people are
hurting themselves
everybody it gets real bad fast on limes
oh look at this what is going on
oh that's definitely a poland
they'll do anything over there
what is going on
the thing is this thing doesn't turn or
twist you can't like you could only just
spin it like this guy's doing like
swirls but
that's that looks expensive yeah that
looks pricey that looks like that's kind
of cheating because the other tricks
built in but i could see that becoming
something yeah
people taking these things and actually
doing oh segway they dropped off i guess
because they were like why do we have
handlebars we can just have the bottom
part yeah like hoverboards remember
those came in for ages and then mike
tyson got like dropped wait is that the
one that be uh that justin was pushing
probably
there's like a video of mike tyson on
one
dude he falls so hard you gotta watch it
mike tyson on a hoverboard right and
he's looking alright
and yeah he gets
he gets dropped
yeah watch
like one of those solid falls too look
oh yeah it's sweet dude you got it
oh
damn i've never seen that bro
you know your sport is one interesting
thing that guys like you know i was
doing this um
you know guys like
people can't just come into your sport
and do it
yeah to a certain extent that's why a
lot of that's why scooter's actually got
um grief from people because it's it's
so accessible like you can you could
jump on a scooter right now i could i
could get you to the skate park you
could drop in like a kid can do it so
easily so it's it's just so accessible
that
like little kids just grab it and they
go you know they have no direction so
they're at the skate park dropping in
and just like getting in the way because
they're just there by themselves that's
all they know they don't know what to do
they don't know the rules yeah and
that's kind of like where we get the bad
rep is because it's so accessible and
kids can just do it instantly and be in
the road and not be like looking out
having skatepark etiquette and that's
kind of gave us a bad rap but it's like
you could do the same thing if
a kid only had a skateboard and he would
do the same thing like just roll around
but it's super hard it's not easy to
just get a skateboard skateboard and
drop in like it takes you a few weeks to
get comfortable to do something and in
those weeks you get told by your friends
hey don't do this don't do that you
gotta wait for this person it's like an
intersection you know yeah you know
yeah uh do you see yourself getting
anything motorized you did you ever feel
like that vibe yeah but it's just so
dangerous man i flipped the motorbike
though travis
travis pastrana's but it it's gnarly
dude that they're so heavy and it's so
wild i've seen we just had last weekend
um our beau bamboo we've done like 20
shows and he fell once broke his
collarbone like in one crash so it's
just like instantly if you fall off a
motorbike it's like you're done yeah
you're like gonna break something
whereas i can fall off get up go try
again like a hundred times motorbike
crash once have you broken a lot
i've been so lucky like compared to the
guys on tour i'm super lucky i haven't
had a surgery yet um only fr i fractured
my ankle
my
both wrists um separated my shoulders
smashed my teeth out fractured my skull
twice oh yeah some of that's just being
australian yeah yeah true 50 is probably
just being australian
um did you watch love on the spectrum
no the australian show the autism
i've heard about that no i haven't seen
it yet
makes me want autism man that makes want
to be australian yeah yeah that's a good
mix yeah it's a and it's a very neck and
neck mix as well yeah you know um
but it's such a good show man um
i'm trying to think of any other
questions that i could think of that i
really wanted to ask you about
um
[Music]
yeah what do you feel like is like
oh dude they have like a lot of like uh
what is what is the babes like how much
babes is out there do they have a lot of
like kind of like
do a lot of the guys and marian girls
that they meet at the track is it that
kind of a universe um it seems like kind
of
like i know it's a big world but i know
it seems like a very specific group
it takes a certain person to like want
to be with like an action sports athlete
it's like kind of like you you're going
to be risking it with them like i'm sure
you'd be nervous like i couldn't do it a
chick that's into action sports like i'm
sure i could but i would be like
freaking out man i can't watch a chick
that's one thing i could watch a dude
slam all day laugh at it yeah
but a chick like falling over i'm like
no
stop
please don't do that so um i can imagine
like it'd be hard but yeah you get you
get tricks coming out i think it's more
the confidence thing like we're just
like so confident in our ability it
doesn't matter if i'm writing a scooter
they're just like this guy really likes
riding his scooter and he doesn't care
so that's right that's it yeah i think
it's confidence if anything you'd be
playing a damn kazoo dude yeah you know
if you're louis armstrong on that [ __ ]
and the ladies will show up
um where are better ladies you think in
the u.s or australia have you found
or do you have a question it is a hard
question but do you have a do you have a
type of woman you think or that you like
one of the other you american or
australian
no no ty it's just like it's like
whoever is just cool you know like um
australian women are a bit like
obviously a bit crazy so maybe i'd gel
better with the crazier yeah i love
australian women man yeah i always
dreamed of maybe going to australia
finding me a little wife or something
little quacker you know a couple
quackers
um
i don't know if did we i feel like we
covered a lot do you feel like that ryan
yeah i think it was i think i've just
been constantly talking so that's it
yeah good pump dude yeah i'm glad i
don't have to speak it's good oh dalia
got up you saw dalia get up that was
cool was that a surprise you know yeah
no i had no clue and like i had been
talking to him because we obviously have
the we have nitro circus in san
bernardino and i was like oh dude gives
you tickets and he's like he was like i
don't know what my one-year-old's gonna
do is he gonna just like not even
understand i was like just get him head
like you gotta get the headphones
because the uh
the bike's pretty loud but you'll be
sick to have him out it was sick to to
see him doing some stand up yeah it's
cool yeah and congratulations on your
special dude oh thanks
yeah it's pretty i'm definitely excited
about it yeah um somebody just sent me a
picture they had a billboard in times
square that was pretty crazy yeah that's
it um
yeah it's exciting man i want to go tour
back over in australia i just got to get
some more jokes i just got to get a few
more stories together they're um
pretty hard to get there though
right
yeah how how that's why the last thing i
was going to ask you is how ridiculous
is it over there oh man it sucks so bad
and the thing the craziest thing is when
i was there i was like oh yeah this
makes sense like everyone's doing it
that's the thing when you're like
blinded when you don't you only see
what's happening in the country you're
like oh it's okay we're all together
we're doing this together for a reason
right no and then they're like oh
america's so bad there's so many cases
like it's just be careful over there and
then i literally got here i gotta get
outside everyone it's like totally
normal right and it's like maybe they
make you wear a mask like here and there
but i don't have to
like i don't have to
quarantine for two weeks in a hotel room
by myself to get into that's crazy did
you have to do that when you left no so
i just had to get uh the um test right
to get on the plane got here sweet all
good
go into the world sir yeah because jim
jeffries just had a tour scheduled in
australia right his home country right
yeah he goes back for two weeks he's in
his hotel yeah and on the last day this
and he's gonna start his tour right
after that all the tickets are sold yeah
they came to him they said
three people down the block had just
gotten covered he has to go back to
america now and his tour was canceled
could you [ __ ]
that would make me kill somebody i feel
like that would make me kill someone way
more man i they've opened up a little
bit in uh certain states so i'm going to
just go chill there because i'm not i
can't sit in a room for two weeks dude
it's like yeah like a prison oh i can
only yeah i mean even when you go to
like um if you go to like other parts of
america it's even more than just totally
normal and you're like even coming to
los angeles seems really really yeah
i was in like nashville and that was
just so wild oh yeah so sick
these two have been doing baseball
stadiums all outdoors it's actually
funny because the moto ramp we can't do
that motor ramp indoors because they'll
hit the roof damn
[ __ ] what's the highest ramp that's
built right now for you guys to be able
to use um so
the ramp that the guy did the quad back
flip off i think it's like 20 foot
like
that's to go forward that's not like the
air to come back down it's like a quad
flip ramp what's the safest ramp that
they can you can technically use right
now um they're not the one that we use
on tour is about 16
foot off the ground could you
could they build a 30 foot ramp if you
wanted or you wouldn't be able to get to
the top of it you'd have to just go so
fast but they could do it like and if
someone wants to do five flips that's
how it goes like if you want to do more
things in the air
it even though it sounds like crazier to
have that bigger amp it's just going to
give you that more time to like get the
trick done yeah because it's like right
now you just pushed first time in the
air oh i see but yeah so do you want
more time up there you think yeah you do
yeah i'll i'll just stay up there yeah
dude
well when you come back down make sure
to come back to the podcast man yeah for
sure all right ryan williams man uh you
guys can check him out uh we'll put all
of his links and everything bruv thanks
so much dude thanks so much for having
me this is like being a dream i've
watched this podcast for so so long i
think like four four or five i know you
and i've been communicating for years
man so it's really really cool man yeah
yeah i appreciate i love australian man
and um i think he might be our first
australian guest so oh no except for
chris lilly yeah yeah so but [ __ ]
pretty sweet i'm pumped on that thank
you so much cheers man cheers
[Music]
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it
in my bones
but it's gonna take
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself
[Music]